révolution au laos une ligne de chemin
de fer est inauguré une voie commerciale
inestimable pour ce pays sans accès à la
mer
ce jour est très important dans
l'histoire du laos il est un nouveau
moyen de transport moderne permettra de
développer encore plus notre pays c'est
un rêve devenu réalité
financé à 70% par la chine cette
nouvelle ligne ferroviaire premier et à
potton ville frontalière un futur
prospère
dans le cadre des routes de la soie la
chine investit des centaines de
milliards en asie du sud-est et surtout
à la hausse avec la voie ferrée
l'autoroute à l'avenir les
investissements de la chine en asie du
sud est ils seront forcément centré sur
le laos
frontières une série documentaire pour
reporter sur france 24 et france 24
points comme